is Ryan Reynolds related to Ryan Gosling
Canada had sex with America and then
they made the two of them and their
twins yeah and both of them tried to eat
each other in the womb but they didn't
they survived and because of the trauma
they both became actors and that's why
the two of them are actors and who they
are I can't feel my life is Ryan
Reynolds missing a tooth what do you no
these are all my teeth what the hell is
going on here Ryan Reynolds is missing a
lot
oh
let's get these calf implants out too
while we're at it
okay is Ryan Reynolds Oh
oh like he's Canadian look you punch it
you punch a couple hundred orphans and
suddenly you're mean I don't this is
what I don't understand